bonjour au revoir merci d'être en direct
avec mon sur rt tran rt france vous êtes
délégué syndical vous représentez des
forces de l'ordre est ce que vous avez
davantage d'informations concernant les
faits qui se sont déroulés ce matin on
le rappelle dans le coeur de la ville de
nice cette attaque au couteau qui a fait
au moins trois morts
écoutez pour le moment je pense que
c'est pas la bonne stratégie
d'information que d'aller à la pêche aux
détails ou d'informations dont
l'essentiel étant que on sait à peu près
ce qui s'est passé et on sait qu'il ya
trois morts à qui on va de deux autres
partis on va avoir une pensée
particulière
on va adresser nos condoléances aux
familles des victimes et à l'ensemble de
la communauté des niçois si vous voulez
c'est le mode opératoire est
particulièrement cruelle
particulièrement barbare donc et on va
dans la continuité ce qui s'est passé il
ya une semaine a confiance à dreux
d'origine il ya trois semaines à devant
les locaux de charlie hebdo donc on
entre dans une époque qui vit comme
dangereuse et il faut aussi par la même
occasion salué l'action de la police
municipale de nice qui est à service
exemplaire dans son organisation puisque
ça fait des années que avec le syndicat
vision met en avant justement là
l'utilité de la police municipale comme
complément gel de l'action de la police
nationale c'est qu'aujourd'hui l'état a
complètement délaissé la sécurité des
français et il faut pas se regarder si
vous voulez de saluer les mères qui
avaient dans la sécurité justement de
leurs administrés et nice est en pole
position justement sur les villes qui
contribuent à la sécurité de leurs
administrés et donc la police qui s'est
passé illustre justement dans
l'interpellation de ce monsieur
écoutez voilà là je pense que ce serait
de mauvais augure que d'aller justement
recherché des détails morbides dans la
façon dont les choses se sont déroulées
puisque je crois que ma cause qu'on en a
il obtient une décapitation
mais ça reste à confirmer voilà soit la
réaction des forces de l'ordre selon
d'après les informations que l'on allait
les
les faits se sont déroulés peu après 9h
assez rapidement on a appris que
l'assaillant avait été interpellé
très concrètement comment est-ce que
s'organise une telle opération
il s'agit déjà de sécuriser le centre
ville comme je vous le disais la
particularité de nice c'est justement un
vêtement qui a été fait sur la police
municipale mais également son réseau de
vidéosurveillance
donc je pense qu'à partir du moment où
signalement a été fait là la police a pu
localiser de façon très précise et grâce
aux justement la vidéoprotection a pu
localiser la position du terroriste et
organiser la neutralisation de celui ci
écoutez on va saluer justement cet
efficace au niveau d'efficacité puisque
imaginez bien que si le terroriste avait
lu les manip qui avait pas eu justement
de l'es22 de vidéoprotection il a pu
faire beaucoup plus demain donc ça doit
donner à réfléchir justement à tous les
maires qui considèrent que la sécurité
n'est pas leur affaire que la sécurité
la sphère de l'état
il faut bien justement lever ce tabou la
vidéoprotection quelque chose
d'essentiel ça a servi justement dans le
cadre de la neutralisation du terroriste
de confiance à leur hymne donc sur la
commune des rallyes est également à nice
donc bon après au niveau des services de
l'état a écouté
bon c'est très bien d'avoir émis une
note de service avant-hier pour dire
qu'il y avait une menace un niveau de ma
date relativement élevé mais il faut
constater que l'état les airs
anciennement aujourd'hui sont
complètement à la ramasse à part dont
l'expression mais si on arrive à avoir
trois attentats en trois semaines avec
des morts à la clé c'est que il ya un
défaut d'efficacité au niveau des
services de renseignements en matière de
détection en matière d' analyse et je
crois malheureusement que on entre dans
une série noire qui quitte il est très
très loin justement de peut-être se
limiter à ce qui s'est passé aujourd'hui
une nouvelle attaque vous l'avez dit en
à peine une dizaine de jours quelles
sont les consignes qui ont été données
ces derniers
jour ces dernières semaines auprès des
forces de l'ordre pour lutter contre ce
genre de faits qui malheureusement vient
se reproduire ce matin à nice
écoutez je voudrais effrayer les
auditeurs mais la note de service a fait
l'objet d'un article sur votre site un
rt france donc c'est une appli est
adressée au préfet une autre qui a été
adressée aux effectifs de police dans
lesquels on y voit comme une fatalité
la commission d' attentat à l'armé
blanche et à la voiture bélier
bon ben ce qu'il faut de toute évidence
c'est le travail et sur les délais de
réaction des forces de l'ordre c'est à
dire que vous imaginez bien que si on a
une voiture bélier que la police
intervient allez on va d'abord meilleur
des cas dans les 5 ou 10 minutes en cinq
minutes on pas en faire des morts avec
une voiture bélier donc il faut à tout
prix essayer d'optimiser le niveau
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre par
une présence massive sur le terrain et
si vous voulez les fans de la cour pas
être au four et au moulin
c'est à dire que si un moment ils ont la
consigne de veiller à l'application du
dispositif sanitaire mais en même temps
à lutter ils sont aussi affectés à la
lutte antiterroriste ça risque d'être
assez compliqué donc il faut prioriser
justement le niveau d'intervention des
forces de l'ordre
si vous voulez l'appeler jeu peut-être
que dans ce contexte là on peut
considérer que le port du masque que
même si c'est important c'est peut-être
pas une priorité absolue quand nos
collègues nos concitoyens pendant ce
fonds décapité sur la place publique
alors on a encore un très peu d'affaires
d'informations sur le profil de
l'assaillant là la façon dont les faits
se sont déroulés mais est ce que ce
n'est pas compliqué aussi comme tâche
pour les forces de l'ordre aujourd'hui
de deux de répondre à une
le nas qui finalement est latente et on
a le sentiment que n'importe qui
finalement on peut être susceptible de
passer à l'acte alors effectivement moi
je m'adapte et je prends le pari que
l'assaillant ne sera pas connue des
sales usa segmenter leur a pas été
détectés au préalable mais de toute
façon il y avait à l'évidence d'une
menace c'est à dire qu'on voit bien que
la réponse de l'exécutif a été
extrêmement mauvaise suite à l'attentât
de conflans sainte honorine c'est à dire
que le ministre a presque amalgames et
celles à l'ensemble des musulmans a ôté
autonomistes puisqu'ils avaient bloqué
des produits halal un certain nombre de
choses de kiki ne relevait pas du
terrorisme c'est à dire que pour bien
prendre conscience que il va rentrer
dans des temps difficiles pour les
membres de la communauté musulmane et
que certains nombreuses de nos
compatriotes musulmans n'ont absolument
rien avec le tourisme et ça aurait dû
être l'heureux des autorités que de
souligner le besoin de cohésion
nationale plutôt que d'amalgamés de
façon j'ai presque démesurée la religion
musulmane avec l'extrémisme de ces
mécanismes un terroriste et donc si vous
voulez ça la réaction à l'international
a favorisé justement l'émergence de
d'actes terroristes comme celui-ci
alors qu'on aurait pu avoir une
stratégie de communication beaucoup plus
efficace associés justement l'ensemble
des musulmans à la lutte antiterroriste
et les unifier la communauté nationale
française dans toutes ses composantes
plutôt que d'amalgamés bêtement le halal
le tennis la communauté musulmane encore
une fois on le rappelle ans pour
l'instant n'a aucune précision sur le
profil de la saion que l'on peut dire
jusque là c'est que ce sont au moins
trois personnes qui ont été qui sont
mortes après cette attaque au couteau
survenue dans le centre de la ville
donner c'est aux abords d'une église le
parquet terroristes anti terroriste a
été saisie une cellule de crise est en
place place beauvau au ministère
de l'intérieur le premier jean castex et
sur place
emmanuel macron est attendu en fin de
matinée il devrait se rendre dans la
foulée à nice loi manoir un tout dernier
mot qu'elle doit être
elle l'a immédiatement la réaction des
autorités écoutez je peux plus me faut
pas surréagir
c'est à dire que la réaction comme ça à
chaud et pas quelque chose de
constructif c'est à dire que la lutte
contre le terrorisme c'est pas du
bricolage
le résultat d'une stratégie pensée
cancer et donc justement l'idée ce
serait de mener l'ancienne c'est à dire
que je pense que dès lors que la
personne sera identifié la police
judiciaire a procédé à des perquisitions
va essayer de comprendre ce qu'il s'est
passé ce qui a amené cette personne agir
ainsi et donc l'idée était d'avoir une
stratégie globale soit prendre ce à
partir d'éléments concrets d'état de
faire des annonces comme ça à chaud dans
les deux heures qui suivent notamment la
commission de l'attentât merci beaucoup
et noir je rappelle que vous êtes
délégué syndical visite collision